Calculemos cuánto es 11 y 12/16 - 5 y 8/16, y
luego podríamos simplificar los términos. Así que
la forma en que me gusta hacer esto es separar
la parte entera del número mixto de la parte
fraccionaria, de modo que puedo reescribir este
número como 11 + 12 / 16 y a eso le voy a restar
y pondré aquí paréntesis porque voy a separar
esta parte, voy a restar 5 + 8,/ 16, 5 y 8/16 es
lo mismo que 5 + 8/16. Pero tenemos que recordar
que estamos restando, estamos restando todo esto,
así que puedo reescribirlo como 11 + 12 / 16 y
estoy restando 5 + 8/16, entonces puedo distribuir
el signo negativo, de modo que esto será - 5, - 1
x 5, y luego -1 x 8 /16 positivos, será -8 / 16.
Y luego me gusta resolver la parte de números
enteros por separado de la parte de fracciones,
así que hagamos la parte de números enteros.
Tenemos 11 - 5, lo escribiré aquí: 11 - 5,
esta es la parte de números enteros, y luego
tenemos más 12/16, más 12/16, menos 8/16, menos
8/16. 11 - 5 = 6, 6 más, aquí tenemos el mismo
denominador, así que obtendremos algo sobre 16,
12 - 8 = 4, así que esto es lo mismo que 6 + 4
/16, que he escrito como un número mixto, es lo
mismo que 6 y 4 /16, 6 enteros y 4 / 16. Esta es
la cantidad correcta, pero podemos simplificarla:
4 /16 se puede simplificar, tanto el numerador
como el denominador son divisibles entre 4,
ambos tienen el factor 4, así que dividamos
tanto el numerador como el denominador entre 4,
dividido entre 4, dividido entre 4. Como
estamos dividiendo entre el mismo número no
cambiamos la cantidad, entonces esto es igual
a, primero está la parte entera del número 6,
y en la parte fraccionaria ahora
es 1/4, entonces obtenemos 6 y 1/4.